An esteemed collection of actors have played
Batman over the decades, and Robert Pattinson
is the newest to join their ranks.
How is his Batsuit distinct from the others?
Keep watching for all the tactical distinctions.
Adam West, Michael Keaton, Val Kilmer, George
Clooney, Christian Bale, and Ben Affleck have
all had their own versions of the Batsuit,
if not multiple variations on it.
Batman's gear is an integral part translating
the more than 80-year-old character from comics
to the screen.
While costume designers get considerable creative
license on other productions, comic book adaptations
have to walk a fine line between translating
costumes that look great in the fantastical
worlds of comics into a realistic film version.
"What gives you the right?
What's the difference between you and me?"
"I'm not wearin' hockey pads."
What did costume supervisor Dave Crossman
and concept artist Glyn Dillon do differently
for "The Batman"?
Pattinson, who originally screen tested for
the role wearing a version of the Val Kilmer
Batsuit, told Entertainment Weekly about his
official costume,
"I felt very different immediately.
It really flowed.
It was so well-designed, so articulated on
all the joints.
It was kind of shocking."
"You trying to get under my cape, doctor?"
As cool as the Batsuit always looked, freedom
of movement has not always been high on the
priority list for the costume designers.
Pattinson's version of the suit makes some
accommodations for that.
It has a collar at the top of the cape around
the neck.
While this may look strange to comic book
fans, it gives Batman protection around his
vulnerable neck area while still enabling
him to turn his head.
In his own interview with Entertainment Weekly,
"The Batman" director Matt Reeves explained,
"Part of the tradition is that when you're
playing Batman [...] you don't just do an
audition, you do a screen test, and they need
to see you in a Batsuit.
But they don't make you a Batsuit, because
that's a very involved process.
So what you do is you put on an old Batsuit."
Pattinson struggled with the heat and the
lack of movement in Kilmer's version.
The costume that was custom-made for him,
by contrast, was almost too comfortable.
Pattinson told EW,
"In the costume fitting, I ended up doing
loads of somersaults and stuff, and then they
added all those into the fight scenes.
You can do like a couple of somersaults in
it, but it really gets old pretty quickly."
Reeves and his design team seem to have ditched
the solid rubber of past Batsuits, adopting
something resembling an actual battle suit.
It all fits with the director's vision of
a more realistic, gritty hero fighting for
his life.
Crossman and Dillon worked hard to echo that
sentiment in the suit.
Pattinson told EW,
"There are little bloodstains on it.
There's kind of grazes where it's been hit
with bullets and kind of just the wear and
tear of someone who's been out fighting every
night.
[...] It looks like a soldier's armor in some
kind of strange parallel universe where you
have to wear little ears on top of your head
as well."
But what about Batman's all-important gadgets?
"Where does he get those wonderful toys?"
While Batman's comics costume places the majority
of his gadgets in his utility belt, Pattinson's
Batman has a more modular and tactical approach,
with devices and weapons built in everywhere.
He said,
"The grapple gun is, I think, in every single
Batman movie, but I'm not sure how many times
he used them so defensively.
It's used as a weapon.
[...] It's kind of based on Travis Bickle,
the gun mechanism, which he has in 'Taxi Driver.'"
There's also apparently a unique use for the
bat symbol on his chest we can't wait to see.
Pattinson explained,
"It's a tool, which he can pop out of the
chest plate, which is kind of amazing, incredibly
difficult to design as well, and looks great."
Wait, like in "Superman 2"?
Probably not.
There also seems to be a gadget hidden on
Batman's leg.
During a chase scene with The Penguin, Batman
causes him to flip his car.
There's a visible bulge on Batman's right
thigh.
Is it a weapon?
A gas mask like soldiers in the field carry?
We'll find out when "The Batman" comes to
theaters March 4, 2022.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.